let's meet the girl shall we first up
please welcome April Ludgate hello I'm
April Ludgate I'm 20 years old I like
people places and things and pani is my
favorite place in the world
so I long for a day when women in
government will simply be seen as people
in government but until then I will work
to make pani my wonderful hometown as
good as it can be what do you think I
think you should lose the first line and
the last line and all of the other lines
and instead just walk up to the mic
and meow really loudly for eight minutes
okay
so you're from Mongolia theme will you
take me with you and you go back there
ooh bleep I love you did you understand
that
did you bring any Wolverines was your
name Jennifer no its tenifer with two
why's it used to be Jennifer but then I
decided to rebrand myself oh wait hang
on it's an X o'clock um well nice to
meet you my name is April and I just
wanted to say that your dress is so cute
it's bongs it's on my spinning
instructor wearing it and I was like
shut up where do I get that oh my god
who's your spinning instructor Gregory
or Winona I go to Yanis who are Gregory
and Winona I've never heard of them
before are they better Winona
rocks my world seriously you need to get
me in there like that's a must must must
she's the worst person I've ever met I
want to travel the world with her I'm
going to do impressions
Oh celebrity impressions that's that's
wild this is an impression of my sister
hi I'm Natalie I love Ritalin and have
low self-esteem
[Laughter]
thank you this is an impression of my
boss Leslie Knope women should do
everything check out my for color pen
hey everybody listen up while I talk
about some really really important stuff
box box box box box if I can show it on
Farscape England's sugar okay folks just
a couple more contestants and then the
judges will decide our next Miss Pawnee
a winner of $600 in gift certificates to
big Archie's Sporting Goods and Emerson
fencing company we don't get cash this
for a fence well it won't cover a whole
fence but I will defray the cost
considerably I quit I quit
okay I guess she really is quitting no I
didn't win but at least I didn't make
any new friendships I don't know my
Leslie knope's on trial has a penis did
it the first time ever in her new
part-time job in the public health
department at City hugs and Meredith
Perkins yay well this is so nice
I put the poisonous gas in one of these
balloons so if any of them pops you may
die okay are you ready for you to tell
me what's going on with Chris yes no to
sing if you're lost you can look and you
will find me time after time go no tell
me about Chris if you fall I will catch
you up be awaited tell me about Chris or
I'm leaving and I don't care about the
letter I want to have a baby and I asked
Chris to donate his firm and he's taking
a really long time to make up his mind
and it's really freaking me out and I
can't stop thinking about it and I'm
obsessing about I want to think about
anything else but that but it's making
me crazy secrets stolen from deepens you
know the song already of course I do
everyone knows the song it's amazing the
drum beats out of time if you're lost
you can look and you will find me time
after time if you fall I will catch you
I'll be waiting time after time time
after time time after time it's never
happened
[Music]
come
when streams are ripe and swelled with
rain
ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today to Mary and Maxwell Dwyer and
April Roberta
led gate I guess I kind of hate most
things but I never really seemed to hate
you so I want to spend the rest of my
life with you is that cool yes babe you
look more beautiful right now than I
have ever seen you Wow just your luck
that you're going into labor on
Halloween can I get a warm towel to get
that makeup off no I went on that's the
whole point I put the makeup on after I
went into labor whatever blows your
skirt up okay you ready to push
wait don't babe my birth mix here comes
a contraction are you ready okay you
[Music]
know what I'm gonna get that commission
going because this inequality has gone
on long enough you know what I think men
are better than women she's kidding no
I'm not they provide for us and we must
obey them because they are our masters
April stop it Leslie
you'll never land a bow with that
domineering tone we must always walk
behind the mesh I believe one problem
with hiring women is that they're frail
and breakable is it possible you're
thinking about light bulbs or your hip
hmm if I were 300 years older Councilman
okay so I took extensive notes on ways
to maximize our efficiency because we
can't be just as good as the men we have
to be better yeah you're totally right
let's rock this April I love you but I
don't need your sarcasm right now
I'm serious let's get rolling I want to
get into some garbage what I love
garbage you ever found a dead body in
the trash where body parts took a torso
or a head please say head this is Stacey
nah blocks house I went to high school
with her and she was super mean to me
and now I know that she dyes her hair
I knew that wench wasn't naturally
blonde oh my god she has to use
prescription-strength deodorant this is
the best day of my life okay Leslie
Knope outfit number eight babe you look
super hot you realize you've said that
about all of them well she has every
single time because she is super hot
honestly even look hot naked oh the suit
makes me want to scold a Catholic child
who Ann Taylor is but I hate her and I
want to kill her I have to lead a public
forum for the Pawnee Commons every day
this week and I hate talking to people
so to get through it I figured I'm just
gonna basically try to imitate Leslie
she still wears this she had the patch
sewn in you can't remove it what's in
the pocket you ask a ticket stub from a
Fleetwood Mac concert in 1995 and this
one is terrible but it is slightly less
terrible than the rest so tomorrow I
read a public forum in Leslie's
Fleetwood Mac sex pants
it would Mac sex pants new band name I
call it you know what why don't we just
say that whoever gets to the emergency
first will be in charge okay so if
there's an explosion say in ramsett park
and someone from sewage gets there first
they'd be in charge I had no idea how
terrible Leslie's job is she referred to
this meeting as a non-stop thrill ride
I'm not quite sure but Tom can answer
that what are you doing
it's bouncing some business ideas off
Russell Simmons on Twitter why all due
respect miss lucky do you even know what
you're doing here all due respect mr.
hamster penis but no I don't
my last name is Geils are you sure
because you look like a hamster penis
what's your endgame here my dear this is
only temporary until I find a way to
keep the shelter open without cutting
the parks budget hey what if I threw
together a pet adoption and in one of
our parks would that be cool April that
would be the coolest thing since NSYNC
Aerosmith and Nelly performed together
at the Super Bowl halftime show no I
think I may have found a project I'd
actually enjoy doing helping these cats
and dogs they should be rewarded for not
being people I hate people so you do a
lot of investing we like to dabble
mm-hmm
I recently invested in some shirts I got
at a garage sale left those at Wendy's
on the way home the economy
[Laughter]
you